I'm Suchitra Sebastian and this is going to
be my new magnet lab at the University of
Cambridge. What my research is about is looking
at complicated materials under very extreme
conditions with the aim of creating new quantum
effects that emerge from trillions of electrons.
So I put on very high magnetic fields, high
pressures and very low temperatures to bring
the material into this special quantum state.
So this lab is something I've specially designed
— I've been designing it for quite a while
now — to provide specific conditions such
that a very high field magnet reaching 21
tesla and going down to very, very low temperatures,
less 10 millikelvin, which is less than -272
degree Celsius. This very special high field
magnet and low temperature refrigerator we're
going to put crystals of these special materials
into this magnet which should be installed
within the next few months and create just
these conditions that you only find in very
few places in the world such that we can create
amazing physics which revolutionizes our understanding
of materials beyond anything we know already.